[Music]
hi guys welcome back to et live I'm
Deidre Behar today is a very exciting
day we've got the stars of Axel in the
building give it up for Becky G and Alex
Neustadter
I am so amped on this movie it is so
different there's really nothing like
this movie kind of explained it a little
bit yeah so Axl its military robotic dog
that has AI capabilities and it's a
story about the dog and his relationship
with this up-and-coming motocross racer
miles Hill and you my character yeah and
and then we team up with Sara and we
kind of formed this this group to try
and you know make sure this dog doesn't
get into the wrong hands and stays out
of those the evil minds yes and Sara she
is such a great female role why did you
love doing it so much because of that
because it felt like she was more than
just a pretty face she's self-made in a
sense you know she hasn't had the
easiest path and although she's you know
young she has a very clear idea as to
where she wants to go and you know it's
there's a lot of obstacles to get there
and I think she's aware of that but
she's there's one thing for sure she
knows who she is and I love that about
her I feel like you have that in common
Tina's in common for sure we love it you
guys I want you to check out a clip
check out the chemistry between these
two take a look
I'm sure I'll be safe here I think you
should be fine tonight no one really
comes here except for me
so you did all these yeah they're
amazing you're really talented so really
quickly before we get started I want to
remind everybody we are live on YouTube
Becky and Alex are gonna be kind enough
to take your fan questions if you leave
them below
I'll get this on this iPad and I will
ask these lovely people all your burning
questions of course I have a few of my
own before we get started on the fan
questions this movie is so cool what was
the audition process like how did this
land in your lap well I originally met
with Oliver daily our director and a few
of the producers and we just kind of
talked about it and talked about the
idea so I met him before and that was
really helpful because I I had an
audition and with like 10 people all the
producers and guys at Lakeshore and and
[Music]
there was like three or four scenes that
we did and and it was very nerve-racking
of course but it was cool I mean it was
just a standard audition process kind of
and and then after that I got a call
maybe a couple days later or something
like that that I got it yeah celebration
yeah very very exciting
and for you miss Becky it's funny
because the the character breakdown and
story breakdown and and Oliver's first
initial idea like his short film the
concept video was sent in an email while
I was filming Power Rangers actually and
I was in such a tug of war between my
music career my first time filming a
movie I was like I don't know if I can
do another one
like I don't I don't know I really want
to like sit down with you know the
director and see what he has in mind for
this character Sara and so that's when I
sat down with Oliver and we read through
the script and he was just really
explaining to me you know that there is
a relatable 'no cebause Sara because she
has a similar story to a lot of us you
know latina girls
up here in the States it's not it's not
easy being a brown girl you know and I
think that story of her and her mom kind
of working for you know this upper-class
American family and kind of just feeling
like the help and you know she lives on
the property and the idea of feeling
like a guest in your own home is like
such a it's like a weird yeah it's like
there's a lot of like contradicting
feelings that come with that but the
fact that she was so strong I think
really really reached out to me and so I
read and everything kind of the same
like standards like audition process and
then got the call couple days later and
I was like alright let's do this
I love it now look I think when you want
to shrim for a part it's always kind of
like a gamble am I gonna have chemistry
with my co-star guys did you do any
screen test beforehand we did oh you did
you good it was we had like a dinner
didn't we or something like that yeah
was it was an instant friendship and
chemistry because I think anybody who
watches the movie you'll see it's really
electric between the two of you it
really just kind of makes sense yeah so
what was it that you guys did off screen
that really helped you master the
on-screen chemistry that was this big
thing of Red Vines - I always find my my
hands reaching for the Red Vine of
course but yeah I think the biggest
thing too is like I think what helped us
bond was the fact that we were filming
in the middle of nowhere
yeah and it was like where wasn't
literally we were like in the middle of
Camarillo Simi Valley now yeah deep sea
yeah a lot of night shoots a lot of
night shoots so you're trying to keep
each other up you're like hey yeah hey
you hey you and yeah no cell service so
you're like well we I guess we have to
be normal people and have normal
conversations right versus you to put
put the the phone technology down yes
well it's so interesting because
technology is a real he
seeming exactly what is your biggest
social media regrets
regret yes I know it can be very dicey
you got to put your life out there for
your fans is there anything you wish you
could have done differently well I don't
really have a social I see you have you
have the accounts but I don't I don't I
just I just I'm not a big I can't do it
right now I don't there's other things
focusing on and ultimately I do probably
want to use it for four causes that I'm
you know passionate about like Arianna
that I work with and other companies but
I I just find that I like to keep my
private life separate from the work and
and yeah I just think that it works
better for me right now
totally I think it's a personal decision
for you yeah I'm like totally I love
sharing everything following you is so
much fun I always watch your Instagram
stories you're so generous with what you
share with your fans yeah is there
anything you would have done different
no there's nothing I would have done
different I mean the truth is is that
you know it's a blessing and a curse
you know social media Tyrion I think one
thing that I've really been reflecting
on lately is that you know I choose what
I share with my fans you know and I
there's special moments to me that I
share with them but at the same time I
want them to know that that's not all of
my life you know it's a very small
microscopic filtered edited you know
small tiny glimpse into what I'm going
through and I think you know there's
this this pressure to be perfect because
of social media there's this perception
that we're always happy and we can only
ever be happy we're like not human
beings right it's just the highlights
superheroes
super glitz and glam me all the time and
it's like the fact that I had to think
twice back in the day is like if I
wanted to like post pictures without
makeup or you know what I mean like I I
started to not care about those things
anymore because the truth is is that
like I am me and I have to like accept I
love that so if I can at least with the
platform you
in a way to encourage people to take
that route with social media yeah so you
know shares share things that you choose
to share not because you think you have
to you know what I mean is there
anything that's completely off-limits
you said that you only share certain
microscopic portions I mean not really
for me I post food pictures latte
pictures yeah pictures of my boyfriend
pictures of my family
I mean I've even I I love that it's a
direct connection to the public to my
fans cuz I believe to like you know no
offense to the media but sometimes they
will do anything for a juicy story and I
think when you can clear the air and
have no filter and and it's like your
chance to speak to your friends directly
like that's that's what I like to use it
for you know it's genuine yeah like an
unfiltered thought totally fan questions
are rolling in we're gonna get through a
few right now Sam wants to know what
does Axl actually look like on set
question yeah he looks exactly like he
does in the movie not CGI no it's not
CGI it's a real animatronic puppet that
three people control and it could
response to anything you do because
there's people that are controlling it
that are listening to you actually
there's person right above you kind of
an engineering there's one inside it and
there's a guy with like remote control
who controls his eyes and actors you
didn't have to like do the dots on the
face and we know you went on a green
screen it was really real like you could
feel that he had a personality which is
so important a lot of times CGI it
doesn't really give that same effect so
it's it's really cool that we had that
it was a little scary but it was so cute
what's so amazing about the story is
that it really is inspired by that that
just straight general idea of a man and
a man's best friend which is the dog and
in this case the dog is a robot but the
the interesting thing about him is that
he has a mind of his own and a heart
like he actually cares for us and he's a
great wingman I mean there's a great
scene in the movie where he he just
knows that my
feeling Sarah a little bit and he just
needs a little extra TLC plays DJ and
link it something going yes you've got
your best yeah I love it
Becky wants to know for Becky will you
be doing more movies Becky I hope so
I hope so I really love it yeah I've
never like I never like trained or
anything I've never gone to like drama
school whatever taking an acting no no I
mean I definitely should I hope I hope
my acting this is Alex veteran actor how
do you think she can know she did great
she fits in perfectly yeah and she just
brings a good vibe and you know she's
very charismatic and brings that
feistiness to it so it's what's another
question both of you can answer this one
we know how much you love Jennifer Lopez
tonight she's being honored at the VMAs
how excited are you for her performance
and favorite JLo video ever let's just
have a moment for Jennifer Lopez for JLo
all right Jenny from the block okay no I
think she deserves it
I think she is somebody who I mean just
look at the blueprint of her career and
every decision that she's made and the
fact that she does it all like she is
not just a singer she's an actress she's
a dancer she's an overall entertainer
producer director she's had clothing
lines vogue and just overall and she's a
mom does it all being ever you know what
I mean like I just I admire her so much
I think she's I think she's dope I think
you're modeling your career very
similarly to hers you've kind of got
your hand in everything you're well on
your way to you know favorite JLo music
video Oh music video oh I don't know
Alex I have no idea I love it I want to
transition from from Axl really quickly
to Power Rangers okay little buzz in the
news last week that there may be a
sequel have you been approached would
you want our camera wanna zoom in closer
to my page
I have no idea actually like I've seen
that's the thing is we because we still
like talking our little like family
group chat like all the strangers yeah
no I mean everybody's now obviously
working on different projects and we
like catch up every now and then where
are you in the world today and we even a
long time ago even before like it was
like made official or whatever like
people were like sending things and we
were like I mean ain't nobody called me
yet so they're doing one without us and
I don't know so we literally we have no
idea okay so you have not spoken with
anyone official at this point but if
it's I mean if it's with the same cast
like I would love that I love spending
time with them they were awesome I
learned so much yeah what do you want to
see Trini do in the future it's so funny
because it's actually kind of like a an
interesting thing because obviously my
character being one of the first
superheroes of that that age to be
questioning her sexuality was like such
a big deal on it really bothered me that
everybody's like Trini needs a hot
girlfriend in number 2 and I was like do
you understand like how Syria isn't how
real what she's going through is and how
many more steps she has to go through
before just getting like a hot
girlfriend like oh like how about the
the duck breakthrough moment at the
campfire
there's together at the campfire scene
where she you know says like this is the
first time I've ever said this out loud
you know then there's another thing how
does that conversation with her parents
and do they accept it do they not accept
it does she get treated differently in
school does she you know does she have a
thing for Kimberly like you don't know
what there could be so many things that
could happen before she just gets a hot
girlfriend so I would love for Trini to
continue and this this journey of
self-discovery to be more sure of
herself because if that's what does one
thing that I can say that was very
different in the characters is Trini was
a tough girl who was masking you know
her confusion and and how lost she was
with being a tough girl you know whereas
to Sarah she's just a badass she just
she's just a tough girl actually a tough
girl yes it sounds like the
Power Rangers producers need to get you
in the writers room Elizabeth Becky's
ready for you
I would I would love to see that happen
so we'll keep our fingers crossed Josie
wants to know how was it working with
each other on this movie it was fun we
had a we had a good time yeah I think
going back to what we were saying
earlier just where we were shooting and
predict predicaments that we were in
with the late nights and being nowhere
and the constant rain it was like the
wettest California winters everybody it
was so strange I feel like those stories
though make for great memories and
filmmaking experiences yeah and like I
think like just overall like everybody
who was casted to be in the film like
when we did like the big party scene
like people actually party we had a good
time there's a party scene in the movie
when you guys go see it it is so lit oh
my goodness I felt like I was right yeah
I do good and they actually like the
food like most of the food was like real
like those Bale pizzas yeah like those
are real like we were able to eat those
oh my god what a dream project you get
pizza you can act with each other your
character without spoiling anything
there are a few aggressive stunts that
you had to tackle was that you or did
you have the help of a stunt coordinator
um the stunts is and the bike stunts or
we had two professional racers or
writers Tyler Barrowman and axel Hodges
who are some of the best legends yeah
they're incredible so they did a lot of
the the big whips and a lot of the big
jumps and then some other stunt riders
who are super talented and amazing that
did a lot of the other stuff they
wouldn't really let me near the bike uh
sadly because of insurance reasons which
makes sense but um but I've I've written
quite a few lately and and got it back
on them so it's all good okay good
your character got a little bruised up
there for a second I got a little
nervous yeah but it's movie magic
imagine no actors were harmed in the
making of Asheville everybody yes and no
robot dogs were actually harmed either
not it's all just right it's all good
yes uh Queen I gotta tip my hat to you
you're just crushing the music scene
they left and right first of all when is
the collab gonna happen between you two
yeah you know he he's not a he's not a
musician he's a lover of music play a
few chords maybe in acoustic myotis
between the daily fun why not super fun
but you know I think it was it was you
that told me in a previous interview
that Jennifer Lopez actually gave you a
great piece of advice to be yourself and
stay in your own lane and I feel like
2018 we've just seen actually sounds so
funny like when you say stay in your own
lane like bu I'm just doing like do not
come to my territory come into my lane
you go I have a problem I know I know
it's all love between the two of you I
think she might just like own your don't
be me bu well that's the thing is that I
think especially with with you no I mean
I don't mean to sound like super crazy
feminist like I think even feminist
sounds like such a strong word like we
should not delay Balaur selves for
anything but I'm definitely about
empowering women in the industry and I
find that you know especially like going
into the latin space like there's not a
lot of us women know and cáñamo know
they they they make it seem like there
can only be one and it's like we all
have different stories and and our paths
have all been so different and we all
represent different flags like you know
what I mean like I think we all deserve
that respect at least at the end of the
day and that was one thing that I
admired about her was that you know
she's so humble I mean the fact that she
took time to take part in a cover of a
song that I did of her song you know and
to sit down with me in the studio and
explain you know you know just stories
of how this song was created and you
know how important it is to like be a
real artist you know like be involved
and the decisions that are being made
because the truth is where the face
we're the ones that have to go in front
of the camera you know at the end of the
day we're the ones have to jump on the
stage and if it doesn't mean anything to
us then eventually you start to get
really tired and you're gonna get tired
anyways because it's exhausting sure but
then other issues start to happen you
know and and she was like it's about you
it's about being
[ __ ] about what you're doing if you're
no longer passionate about it then
that's when you can known to walk away
of course I think your passion has
really come out in the smash singles
that we've heard from you just this year
alone and as a woman I have to tell you
I really sincerely appreciate that
you're fighting the good fight about why
commencing these lyrics and I totally
and I think scene P AMA you did a really
nice job about that scene B Emma for
translation and in English means without
pajamas so thank you that was my
treatment yes Queen I'm like what is it
that that gets you so fired up and angry
and how do you how are you working to
change this narrative well cuz to me
like I'm going back to like the word
like feminist or whatever like my
definition of that is I think different
than a lot of other people because I'm
not saying that we have to live in a
girls-only world that's not at all what
I'm saying I'm just saying that maybe
you know we don't have to be treated so
differently you know why is it okay for
a guy to have a bunch of half-naked
girls in their videos and not be a big
deal but when a woman decides to put on
lingerie and be sexy and be cute and
it's her decision that's when it's like
oh my god it's the end of the world and
so playing with that and and then also
putting a twist on it which is that is a
man's fantasy of what they think our
sleepovers are but at the end revealing
the reality which is sweats onesies face
math.max sleeping you know like that you
know it's fun to play with that because
you're giving people something to talk
about
but you're also saying it's not real you
know and and that was just since we made
the song I just knew this is what the
video had to be and we did just that you
did it
you know a lot of people love to pick
your lyrics apart oh yeah what are your
thoughts on that the lyrics are done
with intention or they meant to be
tongue-in-cheek always supposed to be
yeah because it's like me I'm not
curious as here like it's entertaining
what I mean like music should be fun and
and if you don't like it too it's also
it comes down to like taste you know I
can I can love country music and you can
absolutely hate it and that's okay you
know we should be able to like at least
respect each others opinions you know
what I mean so when people people try to
take what I say so literally it's
actually really funny to me I'm like you
don't need to get your Chinese in the
twist all right like it's not that big
of a deal it's just a phone literally
yeah so for me it's actually more fun
what do you say to people who say you
can't be sexy and a feminist at the same
time I feel like that's something that
is so ridiculous I think that's so
ridiculous because Who am I like
especially women already get you know
put in boxes and so much pressure to
look a certain way to act a certain way
to just from society from what and
especially in Latinas like since we're
kids like they tell us that we need to
be good mothers good wives know how to
you know iron the clothes and wash the
dishes and cook the food and and that's
all we can do god forbid my daughter one
day wants to be a lawyer a teacher a
doctor maybe even a pop star you know
what I mean like it's it's we're told no
since such a young age but guys guys
just get them since they're kids you
know and lot cultures they get to run
around and do as they please until
they're adults and still act like boys
and it's not a big deal and so for me
like Who am I as a woman to tell another
woman you know if I was like you know I
don't like your outfit right now it's
making me feel really uncomfortable when
you actually feel great in it yeah
confident and cue and maybe sexy I'm no
one to tell you that you know what I
mean so you expect the same respect
return exactly that's kind of like you
know treat others the way you want to be
treated and be careful with how you
treat people because you won't like it
when it's done the other way around
karma is an MFR sometimes in the movie
your characters are linked together but
I know in real life you're very very
much boot up if you want to say like
yeah you know two years with Sebastian
you'd posted the most beautiful tribute
on Instagram and I know you're not
married but it feels like you're very
much in the honeymoon stage like it's
been two years but you're just still
sewing each other I mean I guess yeah
there's like a honeymoon phase but then
there's just also like somebody actually
being your friend too and like actually
just enjoying their company and like
them being super supportive to I mean
nah
every guy would be ok with like their
girlfriend you know get into kids
another guide and movie one hello Blaine
P ama
he's very sick no you've not said he
came to visit us said a couple times
like it's it's just nice to find
somebody like in general that's just
awesome like relationships should be a
breath of fresh air and not like a tour
or another thing you have to worry about
like it already takes a lot of work you
know to communicate and keeping a way
even though we live together it's like a
long-distance relationship most times
because he's traveling you know when
they have away games and I'm traveling a
lot so it's just it's just it keeps
things fresh you know how is it living
together is it was it a dance that you
had to do like oh I'm gonna be good at
this you're gonna be good at this like
just go with the flow I always I tell
it's funny cuz obviously being Mexican
like we don't move out until we're
married like it's just like an article
cultural way yes and I remember speaking
to my grandparents about it and they
gave me their blessing because I wanted
you know I want them to feel
uncomfortable
I value you know family morals and in
those traditions and stuff but at the
same time I'm like y'all you know try
before you buy you know like you got to
make sure that you know there's not
seeing that drive you crazy and there's
a lot of things I'm sure I do that he's
surprised you know oh it doesn't bother
me that much or the other way around you
know you're left the toilet seat up
though yes are you yeah exactly but it's
it's it's it's fun it's a lot of fun are
you thinking about the next step at all
no no just I mean don't get me wrong of
course I'm not wasting my time here but
at the same time it's like there's no
guarantee and anything really and and
that's why I think we've made it as far
as we have because we have that approach
of you know enjoy it while we have it
because the truth is is you know he's he
works on a on in a field that the fields
get it funded I know I didn't actually
drive it does happen
he works in a field that literally he
can I mean he can be in Europe tomorrow
you know
and have to play there for a couple
years and and all I can promise really
is that we'll try you know and I think
that's actually really beautiful because
it makes you appreciate every moment
that you have with that person and same
for you you could be in Europe tomorrow
I mean usually I'm everywhere yeah
everywhere Alex I got to put you on the
spot is there a lucky lady out there you
know I don't ever take anything yeah I'm
not taking it too seriously
you know there's there there's a girl
but you know it's I know right there is
a girl there's a girl but you know it's
it's nothing is it's too serious right
now though but it's fun you know it's
it's all good it's all good we're all
doing our best right with the flow
she and actress I think it's cool that
you're the pop star Sebastian's an
athlete like you understand each others
worlds but you're different
how do you feel about dating within your
field I think I think it can be I think
it can be cool I think it's good you
know it's always good to have somebody
that you can relate with you know share
the story yeah and that's also good to
have someone that's completely different
and doesn't remind you of anything and
can just I think there's the best of
both worlds for sure well I'm very happy
for both of you very exciting I do have
to ask you before we wrap up I know that
Demi Lovato was a tour mate of yours a
couple years ago and she's going through
a little bit of a rough time right now
and we're just wondering if you spoken
with her and how she's done birthday
first off happy 26th today they actually
saw her sisters post and it made me
super emotional I yeah I mean it's
something super personal I'm not gonna
let something super personal and and
what I can say is that I'm I'm happy
that she's you know on the right path to
to recovery and the truth is recovery is
never over for someone who's going
through what she's going to do and you
know not a lot of people know this but
it's something really close to my heart
because I have a family member who
suffers of this the same thing and I say
suffer because it really affects them
and it affects everyone around them and
it's a it's a sad thing but I also think
that you know
the other side to that when you can
overcome something and not only that but
share it in front of the world because
that's that's another thing that I
applaud her for and I've always admired
about her she's so real she's always
been so honest and like literally behind
the scenes to you like I've had many
many experiences with her where she's
just so chill and just so authentically
herself and and literally like just
dealing with the idea that the whole
world thinks they know your life better
than you yourself and you're living it
you know that's that's really hard so I
applaud her so much for going through
this in front of the entire world and
and continuing to still be that true on
itself that she is you know she's a
she's a dope chick she's just so
talented and you know has an amazing
family so I applaud all of them I'm
really you know pray I do I think about
it on a daily basis because I'm going
through it myself have you spoken with
her are you textin i definitely reached
out to you know send my best especially
to to her family again me being a family
member of someone who's going through
the same thing get it I get it I totally
get it I mean I can't say exactly you
know everyone's path in life is is very
different but in my personal experience
dealing with it you know firsthand a
it's really hard it's really hard well
the two of you together on tour is an
absolute blast I would love to see the
two of you link up like girl power and
let's put that into the universe yeah we
got a wrap up really quick number one
reason people should go see Axl this
weekend in theatres well I think it's a
great family movie you need nothing more
than these to do but also this dog is so
cool and mixed with the motocross world
it's super exciting and it's just super
fun to go see with everybody in a you
know a theater environment when you're
really immersed in it so yeah it's just
super fun yeah miss Becky yeah I mean
basically what he said I think there's a
relatable Ness to the film that it
doesn't makes it a film for everyone
it's definitely family-friendly lots of
action there's a little love story in
there that's also it's got everything
the girls you know I definitely squeals
and I watched it and I was in it there's
a lot of eye candy I've seen the movie
there's a lot of good-looking people and
and it took me on a real roller coaster
like I'm glad right gonna be a wild ride
ghosts the axle in theaters this weekend
you can keep up with Becky and Alex well
not really Alex on social media he's
gonna come here
and real quick plans to drop an album
that's the thing I feel like oh my god
my fans are watching this and you're
gonna kill me because they're like soon
soon we've heard see and so on at this
point I don't even want to talk about it
because there's so many things beyond my
control like my part is the creative
part which is to create great music but
also I think one thing is is I got sign
up 14 and I'm 21 now and I've never
released an album which is just crazy
but it's also it goes to show where we
are in the music industry and how the
format has changed completely the
digital format now is more based for
singles and don't get me wrong there's a
lot of established artists that are
putting out you know bodies of work and
I as an artist would love to be able to
do something like that but again it's
like totally beyond my control I'm like
sign to three different record labels
and English Spanish and people have
saves and stuff that I you know you know
eventually would want to do but just
don't know I don't know more English
music yes more English music for short
okay definitely good it is a banger we
love it yeah thank you guys for tuning
in go see axle in theaters this weekend
I'm Deidre Behar we'll see you next time
night
[Music]